- HEY, BABE.
- HI.
UM, I MADE A REALLY BIG DECISION
WITHOUT CONSULTING YOU.
I WENT BY A PUPPY RESCUE STAND
ON UNIVERSITY AVENUE.
I HAD TO. I HAD TO.
- YOU GOT US A DOG?
- YEAH, I DID.
- OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD! OH, MY GOD!
- SO, HONEY, I'VE GOTTA
TELL YOU SOMETHING, OKAY?
- MM-HM.
- THESE RESCUE DOGS HAVE
HAD SOME TOUGH SITUATIONS.
- OH.
- AND A LOT OF THEM TAKE ON
THE PERSONALITY OF THEIR OWNERS.
THIS DOG...
- MM-HM.
- WAS OWNED BY RAPPER ICE-T.
ALL RIGHT, LITTLE BUDDY,
COME ON OUT.
- AWW.
- [gasps]
- OH, HELLO,
MY LITTLE DARLING.
OH!
- MAN, [bleep] YOU.
YOU, SUCK MY [bleep].
THIS HOUSE AIN'T [bleep].
- OKAY, BUDDY, TAKE IT EASY.
- A LITTLE TESTY.
- WHOA.
- [bleep] YOU, [bleep].
NOTHIN' EVER BEEN EASY
FOR ME IN MY LIFE.
NOW HOOK ME UP WITH A TREAT.
- YOU WANT A TREAT, BUDDY?
- YOU WANT A TREAT?
- IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT?
HERE WE GO, SWEETIE.
HERE WE GO.
- MM, YEAH, THAT'S
A TASTY-ASS TREAT RIGHT THERE.
NOW GIVE ME THE WHOLE BAG.
- OKAY, ONE TREAT IS ENOUGH.
- BITCH, WAS I TALKING TO YOU?
GIVE ME THE WHOLE BAG OF TREATS
'CAUSE I'M A TREAT KILLER
AND A MOTHER[bleep] HANDFUL.
- SOMEBODY'S GRUMPY TODAY.
- GRUMPY-WUMPY.
- LAY MY ASS RIGHT UP
ON THIS COMFORTABLE-ASS SOFA.
- [laughs]
- I'M GONNA SLEEP ON THIS BITCH
TOO, AS A MATTER OF FACT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
MOTHER[bleep] AND BITCH?
I'M GONNA PISS AND [bleep]
UP HERE TOO.
- NO! OH, NO! NO, NO, NO!
- [bleep] YOU, MAN.
RAISE YOUR HAND AT ME.
- OKAY, UM, I'VE GOT
SOMETHING FOR YOU, LITTLE GUY.
HUH? HUH?
YOU WANNA PLAY FETCH?
YOU LIKE FETCH, HUH?
- GET THAT BALL.
- [bleep] YOU!
BOTH Y'ALL CONDESCENDING
MOTHER[bleep].
I AIN'T YOUR ENTERTAINMENT,
BITCH.
SO [bleep] YOU!
[Dog barking at door]
- OH, WHAT'S THAT?
- GET THE DOOR, OKAY?
UH...
- WELL, HELLO.
WHO IS THIS?
- COME ON, COCOA, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT THESE MOTHER[bleep].
THAT'S MY BITCH COCOA.
OH, I FORGOT TO TELL Y'ALL,
SHE'S GONNA BE LIVING HERE TOO.
- WOW, OKAY, YOU GOT
YOUR LITTLE FRIEND HERE.
- YEAH.
- YEAH, WELL YOU CAN--SHE
CAN PLAY HERE FOR A WHILE, SURE.
- PUPPY PLAY DATE.
- YEAH.
- PLAY DATE?
WE GONNA HAVE A [bleep] DATE.
THAT'S WHAT
WE GONNA HAVE, BITCH.
COME HERE, BITCH.
[sniffing]
[licking sounds]
- OH, HE'S--
- ARE YOU--
- OKAY, HE'S DOING THAT.
NO, NO, DON'T DO IT.
- YEAH, THAT'S MY SHIH TZU.
- OH.
- OH, DEAR.
- GET THE [bleep]
OUT OF HERE!
IT'S ABOUT TO GET GRAPHIC
IN THIS BITCH!
- OH, BOY.
- [licking sounds]
- HOW COME YOU DON'T
DO THAT WITH ME?
- HONEY, I TOLD YOU.
- HE DOES IT.
- I JUST WANT
TO KEEP THIS AREA CLEAN.